i talk so much [ __ ] that i'm like man if
i lose
this is gonna be rough so yeah you put a
lot of i mean that's that's the hard
thing to do when you talk [ __ ] when you
when you play the heel
is so much to perform the pressure is
i mean you have to be good under
pressure it's the conor mcgregor thing
you know the reason i actually started
talking [ __ ] was actually like
indirectly because of george
because
because i would become the opposite of
george
i won my first ebi and i i didn't talk
[ __ ] and everyone was like being like oh
you know he only beat yuri because uh
because he was tired or uh
you know this or that and if they have a
rematch under any of the rules that he
would have lost
and am i trying to figure out what i'm
going to do so i'm scrolling through
george's feed one day and he posted a
clip of him beating someone and i look
at the comments and i'm with this in
mind now my george is the nicest person
of all time and if you look at the
comments it's like 10 000 comments and
like nine thousand and nine hundred are
just people calling him like all you do
is lay and pray you [ __ ] you suck you
can't finish anybody and i'm just i'm
looking at this and i'm like people are
gonna say
what they're gonna say regardless
they're going to talk [ __ ] regardless so
you may as well just say whatever you
want and then just be yourself
is there some aspect as i mentioned
conor mcgregor he uh he crossed the line
with khabib
at least in the eyes of khabib is there
something you ever regret about crossing
a line or does that you ever feel like
there is a line or do you just keep
pushing the line
uh i basically play it per per person i
just i basically fire back with like one
step above what what they do it's always
plus one yeah yeah okay
um so i go i usually go hard like they
fire a bullet then i drop a duke
and then and then after that initial
shot then we go back and forth and i'll
just keep one upping them
so you know there's a lot of people that
love you
but there's also a lot of people that
love to hate you yeah it's so
like what do those people like energize
you or do you just
uh or is it funny to you like what as an
athlete as a performer you should not
think about them it's like a fun thing
it's like it's just like a fun thing
that keeps me occupied
like because like because most of them
that like talk [ __ ] they like just say
stuff that's factually incorrect so then
i just argue with like actual statistics
yeah it's just like
you suck or you're not going to beat
this person i'm like i've already
submitted that guy um so it just it
riles them up and it's just it's just a
fun thing for me to do my down time yeah
your responses are usually very factual
it's very scientific
i appreciate
like you actually you start by talking
trash but then you respond with science
yeah it's great okay it's a good mix
that's a good mix